puis radio canada a obtenu le scénario
qui est préparé par québec en cas de
fermeture complète et prolonge et du
pont champlain on ne souhaite pas mais
ça peut arriver
alors il ya plus d'une cinquantaine de
mesures qui sont envisagées dont deux
nouveau terminus d'autobus au
centre-ville de montréal
alors voici ce qu'a obtenu thomas gerber
l'hypothèse n'a rien d'irréaliste on
connaît l'état de dégradation de la
structure depuis la crise de la super
poutre québec l agence métropolitaine de
transport se prépare au pire
je ne suis pas en train de vous dire
qu'il y aura fermeture du pont mais
notre responsabilité c'est de travailler
pour prévoir le plus de scénarios
possibles dont celui ci mais nous ne
souhaitons nous souhaitons évidemment
qu'ils ne se réalisent pas si on ferme
le pont champlain
moi je dis que ça sera vraiment
catastrophique diarra tu fais le matin
aux banques qui vont se présenter aux
autres à pons 146 mille automobilistes
42 mille passagers d'autobus et douze
mille camions empruntent champlain
chaque jour pour désengorger les autres
ponts il y aurait bien sûr plus de
métros de trains de banlieue et
d'autobus mais ça ne suffit pas c'est
pourquoi québec fait le pari du
covoiturage à grande échelle
une trentaine de voies réservées ferait
leur apparition pour prioriser les
autobus et les voitures de deux
occupants et plus ce sera cas pour
accéder aux autres ponts mais aussi sur
les autoroutes 10 et 20 ou encore
taschereau et la route 132 en ce moment
les gens surtout seuls dans leur voiture
on le voit on le voit dans l'est dans
les statistiques donc il faut changer il
faudra que les gens changent de
mentalité d'attitude mettre l'accent sur
le covoiturage aller voir le voisin pour
s'organiser le matin pour aller au
travail
tous les moyens sont bons pour créer les
voies réservées utilisation des
accotements création de nouvelles
bretelles une partie des terrains de
pratt & whitney à longueuil serait même
mise à contribution
et pour inciter les automobilistes à
partager leur voiture
des stationnements leur serait
spécifiquement réservée au métro
longueuil et aux gars de
mont-saint-hilaire et candiac dans le
même temps des stationnements incitatifs
pousserait comme des champignons sur la
rive sud à sainte julie varennes saint
bruno et beloeil mais également en plein
champ près du quartier dix30 à brossard
même les terrains de l'aéroport de
saint-hubert seraient mises à
contribution
ici sur l'île sainte-hélène des autobus
seront déroutés depuis le pont
jacques-cartier pourra les utiliser le
pont de la concorde
on prévoit même faire appel à des navets
sur le fleuve le centre-ville de
montréal serait également transformé une
douzaine de voies réservées pour les
autobus verrait le jour notamment sur
papineau de lorimier sherbrooke et notre
dame
par ailleurs l'ancienne gare d'autocars
de l'îlot voyageur seraient utilisés et
un nouveau terminus d'autobus serait
mise en place à côté de celui de bonne
aventure
l'endroit est déjà plein à craquer et
l'usagé le réclament depuis plusieurs
années dans ma gerber radio-canada en
rien